You've possibly in the past used remote procedure calls.
This is an example of procedural middleware. The idea here is that,
your piece of a system needs some computation that's available on another piece,
and you'd like to make it look,
in your code, as if you're just making some kind of function call. When really,
the function that's doing the comp, computing is on another machine.
Remote procedure calling, technology hasn't been available since the 1980s.
It is typically synchronous, okay, that is you block until you get
the procedure call comes back. However, it's operating system dependent. And
there have been technologies developed by SUN and, NDR, for dealing
with the data representations and, and the coordination of the call and return.